I me hopefully we should all get
pleasure watching our students rather
than getting annoyed with them if they
don't understand it they don't
understand it I had a lot of pleasure
watching Lisa and George do that and I
got more pleasure at seeing it work over
and over
again what you've started doing now you
started thinking a little bit this time
around you're trying to polish it and
that's when you're back in no man's land
again so what's happening there is I
could just get who was you with this
time same same okay so let's get you up
this
time what what's happening there
is
you're what's it in
Spanish in Spanish
the
I want you to
watch okay so where it's now gone WR is
it's become peaceful it wasn't peaceful
first time do you know what I mean you
were dynamic Dynamics you changed into
different techniques now you watch your
hands and that they've all become very
peaceful he's still falling down he's in
the right places but he's used to
training isn't he so he's actually
working on memory he not what he's not
actually being thrown he's blending so
is he so in a way he know he didn't hear
me correct he's actually correct because
there is no UK they're both doing IID
because they're both
blending so this point what you need to
add now is you need to add that forcing
yourself right it doesn't to be in a bad
way I just have to get in there me going
yeah I can do it like
this do it this lovely it's lovely I
love it it's it's a martial
art you need
that
without I mean I don't he any the KY
nowadays but you don't have to KY ey to
have that com out of your
body so I'm not telling you off all I'm
saying is that's what happens this is a
stage I can get him right now i' done it
and I did throw him down but I also with
my vision this hand and my hand was too
far
apart so what I done is just it's really
just wasted knowledge P but what I done
was I had to hook him up in my head and
I had to go go over there so I had to
switch from physical to mental theopathy
if you like you don't have to believe in
all that but but that's what I had to
quickly do that cuz I knew I lost him
with the
hand you know stuff we don't teach
you you're you're on your own now ton so
I can s any long I died you know so you
take what he taught you and you try to
work out what he said but you didn't
hear so you know you you go over the
time so you're
here I'm forcing this even though I
don't need this Force
peness of power on everybody I need it
within myself I need it within
myself to keep my aura
growing my aura my
energy I have to I have to keep that
expanding so at your level you'll be one
two
three
watching being
dynamic